you guys congratulations first of all
best unscripted thank you
i mean you guys beat out kevin hart the
drag race queens like how does it feel
now that you have the trophy in your
hand it doesn't feel real i feel like
we're we're not going to be able to
process this until we go home and like
what the heck just happened but i'm very
excited they're so cool
and everyone in the category was so
awesome so like even to be in that
position was
so cool but um this is actually super
cool and what a flex because it's after
the first season come on that's that's
that's crazy and it only
seasons only get better from here so
okay she's selling the show already she
knows she goes just wait till season two
right exactly i mean did y'all ever
imagine that your passions and your
talents in life would lead you to this
place with this amazing fandom i mean i
think
even throughout filming season one we
were so unsure of
ourselves and our own journeys when we
were going through it and getting to see
how people reacted to season one and how
it's been able to help people whether
it's mental health or figuring out just
regular
growing up stuff i think it's
been very awesome and it feels really
good to know that that had an impact on
some people dad you're beaming i can
tell i see i think you're hearing that
must feel really special yeah i'm so
proud of
these three ladies and um it's been a
really fun ride and we're super blessed
to be doing what we're doing and
grew up loving mtv and this is
incredible honor
hello i'ma let you guys go cause i know
there's a heavy and you guys are already
like suffering from injuries
congratulations